the fallout's still coming in fast and
furious over the fbi's raid on former
president trump's mar-a-lago estate
republicans demanding answers from the
white house and the doj as we learn
brand new details here they are the fbi
reportedly searched through the former
first lady melania trump's wardrobe and
spent hours in trump's private office
seizing about a dozen boxes on monday
some of the materials recovered from
earlier this year included letters from
kim jong-un and former president obama
as well as a cocktail napkin and a
birthday dinner menu an attorney for the
former president telling jesse our own
jesse waters that the fbi would not let
trump's legal team keep a copy of the
presented search warrant
our country should be terrified i am
terrified i can tell you that he was not
only working with them he was
cooperating there was nothing to hide
and he was working in tandem allowed
them into mar-a-lago and the point is
they went in when he wasn't even there
and then told his attorneys to leave why
doesn't the president's attorney just
release the warrant they were probably
handed a warrant actually um my
understanding from the attorneys on the
ground was that they weren't given the
warrant they were allowed to see it and
then taken back
and fox businesses charlie gasparino
reports that trump and his legal team
will likely seek a court order to force
the fbi and the justice department to
turn over a physical copy of the search
warrant the affidavit and a complete
inventory of what was taken in the
mar-a-lago rate meanwhile there's
growing speculation among republicans
that the fbi raid on mar-a-lago could
actually accelerate a trump 2024 run for
president
i've never seen president as president
trump as fired up as what he was tonight
he is not deterred and if anything it
paves the way for donald trump to unify
the party once again and run for
president all right so did i miss
anything sure welcome back by the way
and i gotta say you look great i mean
the swelling is down you look you look
10 years younger
thank you it's amazing you know it's
weird that when you go for one of those
procedures you have to socially distance
for 10 days
it's like a strange thing it's like a
weird pandemic thing that's happening
indeed but i'll come back to you jesse
um it's true no one is above the law but
while the silence continues from doj and
the white house
and the fbi that it is understandable
that people are suspect about what's
happening here yeah biden rated trump's
house and then went on vacation and he
took hunter in air force one with him
that's crazy i think newsweek reported
that they had a mole inside mar-a-lago
which doesn't surprise me remember they
put moles in the campaign
put moles all over the place they
probably put them all at fox the fbi
it's what they do i don't even believe
there was a mole that's just like a
justification to say oh someone told me
they bought a safe that's why we went in
now this archivist who started this
whole drama this guy's a total weirdo
obama appointee said january 6th was the
worst day of his life
okay he wasn't at the capitol on january
6. the archives are blocks away must
have had a pretty nice life as a
librarian um he said that
he saw on television
trump leaving for malaga on inauguration
day with a box and he goes what is in
that box and that's when this whole
thing started
now
obama's got boxes of stuff in chicago tr
you know biden's got stuff at the
university of delaware remember you
can't see it when he got accused of rape
you can't see it but trump's not allowed
to have a love letter from little rocket
man they judge shop first of all to
probably the worst magistrate judge in
the country why would you shop for a
judge who worked with the epstein team
like you know he represented the pilot
the pilot that flew children to an
island to get raped now usually if you
fly children to an island to get raped
you usually spend time in prison but for
some reason this guy spent no time in
prison because this guy they shop to
either got him a sweetheart deal and he
didn't even
he didn't even leak and rat out epstein
he still got off and he's all over
social media saying oh i hate president
trump i love joe biden that's who they
went to and i think judicial watch just
filed a foia request so they have until
monday to explain the doj why they did
this and show the the affidavit the
surveillance video at mar-a-lago exists
so i think they should release that to
show these guys rummaging through
melania's closet what do you think the
president went in there and like stuffed
things in her in her in her undergarment
and like sewed documents inside of her
dresses so they couldn't see it that is
absolutely crazy i wouldn't be surprised
also if they planted bugs i mean they
did bug the campaign they fraudulently
doctored evidence to get a warrant to
wiretap the campaign i'd sweep that
whole estate with a bug sweeper whatever
those things are called you see those
things on the beach or something like
that so the ag's in hiding biden's in
hiding and
let me get this straight democrats are
so upset about being hacked and all
these sensitive materials out there
right
so hillary gets hacked and and everybody
has that
obama's white house got attacked by
chelsea manning
gets hacked by who was the other guy
snowden releases documents everywhere uh
joe biden's son loses his laptop that's
all out there his daughter's diaries out
there for everybody to see so that's
fine so the democrats just like throw
documents all over the world everybody
can see it
but trump has a letter from kim jong-un
that they have to raid his estate over
give me a break trump should have just
lit everything on fire that's what
crooked did
crooked bleached everything and said i'm
going to destroy the personal stuff
here's the work related stuff i mean why
didn't trump do that jessica
do you get the sense that democrats are
feeling some pressure for the fbi or the
doj to at least say something about
what's happened well i'm glad that we're
back to using hillary clinton's legal
birth name crooked diane
rodham
crooked rotten clinton
it's beautiful
i didn't say who's saying i did not say
who's saying obama
how big of you um there's definitely
some pressure out there you saw andrew
cuomo
came out and said yesterday that we've
got to hear about this he's not
necessarily in good stead with the party
but he is certainly a prominent democrat
i think people generally want answers i
think everyone is unified the reason
that they want those answers are
different and democrats are certainly
looking at this and how it's been
portrayed in terms of punditry and the
kind of articles that have been written
about this and the comments that have
been made and our our heads are
absolutely spinning it's the number of
missed truths and assumptions that are
being projected all over television i
mean from the idea that there was
evidence that was planted donald trump
is now amplifying that um eric trump
went on tv and said that uh biden
definitely signed off on this i don't
know if he's just tattletailing on how
his father used to do things but the
biden administration has made it clear
that they found out because biden always
tells the truth like oh i don't know
what my son was doing with the chinese
you believe him
do you believe biden when he says i
didn't know anything he also said he
didn't know anything about what hunter
was doing
i can't even do it because i don't
always time on the idea that biden sat
around and signed you know signed to
said oh hey merrick this is what we
should be doing now
i'm sorry but shouldn't he know should i
it's the president he's in charge i
don't know the doj they're supposed to
function separately from them
okay
that's not just that this judge by the
way who donated to president obama and
to jeb bush um now he had to have his
information scrub from the internet he
and his family have been threatened
about kelly supreme court justices when
they could have done something about it
as a judge
kidding no all i hear about at this
table by the way is that it's only
democrats that are you know crazy
unhinged violent types we have evidence
this happened in a day that this man
isn't going to have to go into hiding um
we heard also from the attorney who
appeared on your show saying that no
none of trump's attorneys were allowed
to be present newsweek reported that
lindsey halligan from trump's team was
president was present during the
multi-hour search
bad information is dangerous here if the
trump campaign or i shouldn't say
campaign admit if the trump group team
has the warrant or any information on
what they see they should release it
that burden is not on the doj to do it
if he's going to say that they planted
something
prove it he's presumed let me tell him
all right
whose burden is it yes who drafted it
exactly let me let me get back up for a
second
harold yesterday his whole defense was
tell us what was in the warrant tell us
what was in the warrant that was the
defense of the democrats well donald
trump didn't get a copy of that warrant
neither did anyone on his team i spoke
to eric trump 10 minutes before this
show they were not allowed to get a copy
of the warrant they were not allowed to
have any of the attorneys on scene there
while the
last thing
again let me finish you believe newsweek
wait a minute i don't believe newsweek
but let me make my point here i was a
judge
you decide a warrant based upon the
application and the affidavit we know
that the fbi has no credibility because
the fbi put in affidavits before fisa
judges regarding regarding national
security that were based on lies and
trump haters who wanted to make sure
that hillary clinton won that same crew
that called us domestic terrorists who
then lied about making sure donald trump
wouldn't be president we're supposed to
believe them and let me make something
right my trump appointee christopher
wright
much a christopher
of the deep state as the rest of them
now let me explain something about
christopher ray
did not he was called to answer before
congress he couldn't answer anything two
weeks ago about what was going on in
congress in terms of what he's doing
with the fbi how he's punished any of
the people whether it was mccabe or
strzok or the rest of them he did
nothing zero zilch all right now let me
tell you a little bit about this warrant
they can put anything they want in the
warrant it is the execution of the
warrant that is filed with the court
that contains what they got now how did
they take those boxes in judiciously is
the war that was used that means they
took boxes they did no inventory we
don't know what was in the box they set
it up so that they can say anything was
in that box and to go through melania
trump's clothes it's an outrage this is
a this is their effort to intimidate the
trumps and make sure that the trumps are
not in a position where they can deny
anything and at the end of the day here
what we've got is a corrupt justice
department a corrupt fbi based upon what
has happened in the last seven years
they've gone after donald trump for
seven years they will not stop the fbi
the doj the attorney generals they want
him on anything and i'm telling you sure
as i'm sitting here the guy's going to
run for president now because they
pushed his buttons all right i have done
a great job of managing this blog um
over time but i want to give you time to
either make fun of me or to make a
comment oh no i will i'll make a few
comments i will i have to address
jessica's point about the threats to the
judge i think that as legitimate as
those threats might be
you're seeing the pivot from it's not
about the raid it's the pouncing of the
right this always happens when something
happens oh well the right is now
pouncing and that's their way of
pivoting away from the actual injustice
and i do think that jesse is right to be
skeptical of everything that is coming
out of these departments when you
consider that all of these people
believed that number one trump was an
existential threat number two he was the
next hitler right so if you didn't want
to try to get him off the political
landscape then you're kind of a coward
right if you actually believe yeah
you're complicit if you so so the thing
is they can't argue that he's evil and
then do nothing about it including go
above the law if i felt that there was
somebody that was running for president
who was hitler an existential threat i
would break the law like i would if i
could go back in time and kill hitler
that's always the question you would do
it so you know that's the the i you
can't say this about trump and then say
you're going to be below the law they
also went through melania's closet which
is you know imagine if they did that
with hillary right they'd find one pant
suit and a server and they went into dr
jill's closet they find an online degree
and 30 cases of prevagen and if they
went into joe's closet they'd find
robert byrd so i could i would argue i
would argue that whatever you're talking
about it it goes back to the simplicity
that a lot of the things that trump did
never were never was by the rules
because he didn't really like he he was
outside that world so he took this stuff
home and it's like i don't care it's i
got some napkins i got a signed photo i
got some stuff from jesse
and then it's like and then it's like oh
they want it back and he's like oh
that's my stuff i can see that that
could be that could that's how he looks
at it but the motives to go after him
make me think that they do want trump to
run and this is very reminiscent of
2015. egg the guy on talk about him as a
joke and a threat watch the ratings
explode suddenly he's on morning joe
every single day but basically jeff
zucker is sucking on his toes and then
they're drooling over the guy and then
what happened they elected him
and now their trump derangement has
created him an amnesia and they're
doomed to repeat it again remember this
uh uh tyrus said this last night on my
on my show it's a all it took was a joke
at the correspondence dinner to get
trump to run yeah what do you think this
is going to do not only is he going to
run he's going to unite everybody behind
him because you just did something so
incredibly visual you raided his house
lastly they got the ball rolling on
retribution right now
what do you think you think you know you
see colbert laughing about this is it
going to be funny when a republican is
in there and decides to go after joe
biden but joe biden's been in politics
for 50 years god knows the amount of
shady dealings going on in his life
that's i mean they're the sopranos with
a sex addiction so this is not a this is
not a good pattern to start to go after
the previous president but now all bets
are off let the pouncing begin
he actually just did something really
bad and he shouldn't have done it you
have 15 boxes carter away already 10 to
12 this time around he cooperated with
them no he didn't that's how he
cooperated with him it doesn't make it
jessie tonight
it's just the sandy burger thing really
pisses me off from 2001 when they tried
to hide the fact that the clintons
actually did know about al qaeda exactly
that's irritating because they stuffed
them down his pants and his socks and he
got probation i went on brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now